willkommen an der Militärakademie miner
Neustadt ich bin Oberst Markus Reisner
ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs und
Entwicklungsabteilung der
Theresianischen Militärakademie und
derzeit der Kommandant der Garde in Wien
in unserem heutigen Video wollen wir uns
das Ergebnis der ukrainischen
Sommeroffensive ansehen wir haben uns
für dieses Video extra mehrere Monate
Zeit gelassen weil wir ein finales
Ergebnis der Offensive abwarten wollten
und jetzt D nach 195 Tagen bzw nach 660
Tagen Krieg kann man auch tatsächlich
eine erste Analyse wirklich
durchführen am Beginn möchte ich ja noch
zwei Folien zeigen von unserer letzten
Präsentation Ende Mai unmittelbar vor
dem Beginn der ukrainischen Offensive
was war damals die vermutete Idee der
Ukrainer die Idee der Ukrainer war es
mit einem zentralen Stoß Richtung A
sofsches Meer vorzustoßen und die
besetzten Gebiete in zwei Hälften zu
teilen in einen Bereich im Raum donjetzk
und in einem Bereich im Raum Krim
saprosche und kerson mit einer Brechung
der zentralen Versorgungslinien einmal
über die Brücke über die Straße von
Kersch und auf eine Unterbrechung der
landlinie Richtung Südosten wäre die
Idee gewesen diese Kräfte hier zu
isolieren und damit Russland an den
Verhandlungstisch zu zwingen wenn wir
uns auf der zweiten Folie ansehen die
Möglichkeiten so war er klar zu diesem
Zeitpunkt dass die Ukraine signifikante
Kräfte zusammen gezogen hat und sie mit
vor allem westlichen Waffensystemen
ausgestattet hat wie z.B Leopard
Kampfpanzer oder welkampf
Schützenpanzer die Idee des Gefechts so
wie wir es vermutet hatten war dass die
Ukraine versuchen werden vor allem mit
aenkungsangriffen im Nordosten die
Russen zu zwingen Reserven zu verlegen
bzw auch mit Kräften im Süden zu
versuchen quasi über den tneep zu gehen
und dann an drei zentralenstellen
anzugreifen heute wissen wir dass
tatsächlich die Ablenkung nur zum Teil
funktioniert hat das auch nur das
Unterbrechen BZ zweite Angriff auf die
Brücke über die Straße von Kersch nur
zum Teil funktioniert hat und dass der
Ansatz im Süden aufgrund der Sprengung
des Nov chakovera stautams nicht
funktioniert hat aber es kam am 4 juni
zum Angriff der Ukraine an 3 zentralen
Stellen einmal grob im Raum parkmut
sowie einmal nördlich von mariopol und
einmal nördlich von
militopol die große Hoffnung war dass
die aus dem Westen gelieferten
Waffensysteme darunter auch moderne
Kampfpanzer von Typ Leopard oder
Challenger den Unterschied machen würden
tatsächlich war es aber so dass der
Angriff einen anderen Verlauf genommen
hat denn die Bilder die man gesehen hat
waren diese im Wesentlichen mit Beginn
des 4 Juni war es der Fall dass die
Ukraine in ein tiefgestaffeltes
russisches Verteidigungssystem gelaufen
ist und wir wissen aus einem Bericht der
Washington Post das general solus der
Oberkommandierende der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte nach vier Tagen tatsächlich
diesen Angriff abgeblasen hat ich gebe
ihen jetzt hier ein Beispiel für diese
ersten Stunden des Angriffes anhand
eines Videos in diesem Video sehen Sie
Teile der 47 mechanisierten Brigade wo
sie auch das zerstörte Gerät hier sehen
die versuchen hinter minenräumgeräten
Richtung der russischen Stellungen
vorzugehen aber dieser Angriff bleibt im
Feuer der russischen Kampfhubschrauber
die SEER Distanz von bis zu 10 km
gewirkt haben
[Musik]
liegen
das Video hat uns jetzt sehr gut die
ersten Momente dieses Angriffes gezeigt
wenn wir uns nun im Detail ansehen was
gut und schlecht funktioniert hat dann
kann man eine sehr genaue Ableitung
treffen was es in den ersten Stunden
sich tatsächlich hier ereignet hat
nehmen wir dazu als Beispiel eine US
Vorschrift die sehr genau beschreibt was
zu berücksichtigen ist welche
Fähigkeiten notwendig sind um einen
derartigen komplexen Angriff
durchzuführen es ist im Prinzip eine
aninanderreihung von Begriffen der erste
Begriff ist der Begriff niederhalten
hier geht es darum dass der Gegner so
niedergehalten werden soll damit die
eigenen durchbruchskräfte im Prinzip
ihre Arbeit nämlich den Durchbruch durch
die Verteidigungsstellungen unbeschadet
tatsächlich erfüllen können das hat
nicht funktioniert warum weil es eso
nicht gelungen ist die russischen Kräfte
die russischen Fähigkeiten abzuhalten am
Beginn der Offensive Beispiel eben die
das Video gezeigt mit den russischen
Kampfhubschraubern der zweite wichtige
Begriff ist der Begriff des Verbergens
hier geht es darum den Gegner die Sicht
auf die eigenen Kräfte zu nehmen damit
die quasi die Arbeit also das
Durchbrechen oder das Räumen z.B von
Minen erfüllen können auch das hat nur
zum Teil funktioniert wir haben in dem
Video zwar gesehen den Einsatz einer
Nebelwand aber wissen heute dass von den
eingesetzten Granaten bei der Offensive
nur ca 3% für den nebeleinsatz
vorgesehen waren offensichtlich zu wenig
um diesen Begriff des Verbergens zu
erfüllen der dritte Begriff ist der
Begriff des Sicherns hier geht es darum
zu verhindern dass der Gegner wenn er
erkannt hat wo die vermutete
durchbruchstelle der eigenen Kräfte ist
entsprechende Reserven zum Einsatz
bringt das heißt man versucht quasi im
Prinzip der Einbruchstelle abzugeln und
zu verhindern dass der Gegner auf die
eigenen Kräfte wirksam werden kann auch
das hat nur zum Teil funktioniert es
waren vor allem der Einsatz von
russischen beweglichen Panzer bei
lenkwaffentrups der dazu geführt hat
dass es nach dem Einsatz der russischen
Kampfhubschrauber zu weiteren sehr
schmerzhaften Verlusten gekommen ist der
vierte Begriff der wichtig ist zu
verstehen das ist der Begriff wo es
darum geht zu reduzieren und zwar es
geht darum die physischen Hindernisse
die der Gegner quasi ins Gelände gelegt
hat zu reduzieren das heißt die
Minenfelder zu räumen einen Panzergraben
zu überschreiten
z.B die Drachenzähne auf die Seite zu
schieben oder den Stacheldraht der
vorhanden ist quasi zu reduzieren und
auch das hat da nicht funktioniert vor
allem z.B bei den Minenfeldern die oft
eine tiefe nicht wie aus dem leerrbuch
von 120 m hatten sondern sogar bis zu
500 m und nachdem diese vier
grundsätzlichen Fähigkeiten nicht
erfüllt waren nachdem es also kein
niederhalten des Gegners gab nachdem es
kein verbergen der eigenen Kräfte gab
nachdem es nicht möglich war die
Einbruchstelle zu isolieren und nachdem
es kaum möglich war tatsächlich auch das
gegnerische verteidigungsdispositiv zu
verringern durch den Einsatz von
räumkräften war es nicht möglich
wirklich in den Angriff zu gehen damit
hat der Angriff der an drei Stellen
vorgetragen worden ist nicht durch
schlagen sehen wir uns das noch einmal
kurz im Gelände an was denn hier für
Fähigkeiten auf beiden Seiten verfügbar
waren oder welche Fähigkeiten gefehlt
haben auf der einen Seite die russische
Verteidigungsanlage die Russen hatten
6ch bis 7 Monate Zeit um sich hier
einzurichten sie haben also eine
Kombination von physischen ins Gelände
gelegten Verteidigungseinrichtungen wie
Minenfelder Stacheldraht Drachenzähne
und ähnliches bzw auch natürlich Kräfte
die man bereit gehalten hat wie mobile
Reserven einerseits mechanisiert aber
auch Banzer lenkwaffentr trups
entsprechende Störer um das
elektronische Feld zu beherrschen
Artillerie in der Tiefe und vor allem
der Einsatz von luftmitteln wie
Kampfhubschrauber die einer sicheren
Distanz wirken konnten
erdkampfflugzeuge aber V allem auch der
Einsatz von Drohnen einerseits zur
Aufklärung aber auch gezielt das
angribsmittel die ukrainische Seite
hatte tatsächlich einiges an Gerät zur
Verfügung um dem etwas entgegenzusetzen
das heißt man hat also entsprech
räummittel aber das Problem war hier
nicht in der Menge die man gebraucht hat
man hat entsprechend kampfkräftige
Verbände dahinter also Kampfpanzer
kampfschützenpanzer moderner Art
verfügbar gehabt aber was ist das
Wesentliche ist man hatte zu wenig
kampfunterstützung und auch kaum
Luftunterstützung verfügbar vor allem
der Bereich der Luftunterstützung wäre
ein sehr wichtiger gewesen denn mit
diesen Mitteln wäre es möglich gewesen
die russischen Kräfte sow weit abzunüzen
dass es quasi dann der Stoß entsprechend
durchführbar gewesen wäre an dieser
Stelle ist auch zu erwähnen dass es zwar
entsprechende Unterstützung durch
weitreichende Artillerie gegeben hat
aber nicht in der Menge in der man es
gebraucht hätte es gab zwar den Einsatz
von heimas und von rohrartillerie aber
es haben z.B gefehlt diese sehr
wichtigen und bis zum Schluss ist nicht
eingetroffenen Army tactical missiles
diese attackams die man auch gebraucht
hätte wenn wir uns n das Ergebnis im
Gelände ansehen so kann man erkennen
dass zwar am Beginn taktische Erfolge
erreicht worden sind man konnte einige
Ortschaften die auch wichtige
Stützpunkte waren in der russischen
Verteidigungsanlage tatsächlich in
Besitz nehmen aber der Vorstoß war an
vielen Stellen nur wenige Kilometer wir
hier in diesem Bereich der westlichste
Vorstoß nördlich von dogmark bzw
nördlich von minitopol wo es zwar
gelungen ist rapotine in Besitz zu
nehmen und auch Richtung WB vorzustoßen
und damit also auch die ersten Linien zu
durchbrechen aber nicht weiter
vorzustoßen und man erkennt den diese
wirkliche Ablage erst wenn man sich das
Gelände im ganzen ansieht denn hier
haben wir noch einmal diesen Vorstoß von
knapp 8 bis 10 km der natürlich sehr
gering erscheint in Vergleich zu dem
über 100 km die man gebraucht hätte um
Richtung Süden vorzustoßen und das hat
sich also nicht nur hier im Raum
nördlich von dogm so abgespielt sondern
auch im Raum nördlich von bertansk und
mariapol wo dieselbe Intention im
Prinzip vorhanden war wenn wir uns nun
im Detail noch einmal die russischen
Verteidigungsanlagen ansehen so kann man
erkennen dass sie ein sehr ausgegügles
System angelegt haben einerseits von
einer
gefechtsfahrpostenline die die Ukraine
nach mehreren Tagen tatsächlich auch
durstoßen hat aber dann dahinter die
wirklich tief gestaffelten
verteidigungssystemen zum Teil auch
parallel in die Tiefe gelegt wie in
dieser Linie kenar 1a und 1b dann eine
weitere Linie die Nummer 2 in der Tiefe
und dann die unmittelbare Befestigung
der wichtigen Ortschaften oder Städte
wie in diesem Fall docmark die
ukrinische Seite hat es geschafft die
gefechtsverbostlinie zu durchbrechen und
den Fuß in die Türe zu bringen das heißt
praktisch in die erste
Verteidigungslinie einzubrechen zwischen
rapotine und wboe aber sie konnte nicht
weiter
durchstoßen
die Frage ist was hat dann Fähigkeiten
gefehlt und hier muss man also ganz
offen ansprechen dass wesentliche
Fähigkeiten nicht verfügbar waren oder
in zu geringe geringe Menge verfügbar
waren das erste was von ich schon
erwähnt habe ist der Einsatz von
Systemen die in die Tiefe wirken können
hier war so dass eigentlich zugesagt war
dass die sogenannte ground Launch small
diameter bomb verfügbar gewesen wäre sie
aber nicht vorhanden war und auch jetzt
nicht zur Verfügung steht sondern erst
nächstes Jahr geliefert werden kann es
gab eine Menge von
luftbodenwaffensystemen wie vom Typ
Storm Shadow oder skalalp aber hier ist
nicht das Problem die Quantität und die
Qualität dieser Waffensysteme sondern
die verfügbare Quantität an Plattformen
die diese auch einsetzen können wir
wissen dass die Ukraine im Prinzip knapp
zwei Handvoll von diesen su24 m hat die
dazu umgebaut worden sind aber auch hier
sind also zu wenig vorhanden gewesen und
das dritte Element das waren die
Brigaden der Offensive die man
eingesetzt hat neun Brigaden vom Westen
ausgestattet und drei von der Ukraine
diese 12 die offensichtlich nicht über
den entsprechenden Ausbildungsstand
hatten wie vorher erklärt um diesen
erfolgten Durchbruch zu erzielen das
heißt wir hatten also hier nicht
verfügbare Systeme wir hatten zu wenige
Systeme und wir hatten offensichtlich in
der Ausbildung Herausforderungen die
sich in der Zeit nicht bereinigen lassen
konnten wir wissen sehr genau Bescheid
über das Ergebnis der Offensive nicht
zuletzt aufgrund eines Artikels in der
Washington Post tatsächlich eigentlich
zwei Artikel die veröffentlicht worden
sind am Beginn des dezember und in
diesem Artikel geht man sehr kritisch
ins Gericht mit der Planung dieser
Offensive und wenn wir uns hier im
Detail ansehen die tatsächlichen
dargelegten Schilderungen so kann man
erkennen dass es z.B eine Diskrepanz gab
zwischen der Art und Weise des Angriffes
von der amerikanischen Seite wurde
favorisiert dass man an einer zentralen
Stelle angreift nämlich nördlich von
militopol bzw dogm während die Ukraine
gesagt hat sie möchte an drei Stellen
angreifen nämlich bei bmut
dann nördlich von mariopol und bei
militopol so wie auch von uns damals in
diesem Video vermutet und auch
dargestellt und das hat natürlich aus
amerikanischer Sicht dazu geführt dass
die Kräfte zersplittert worden sind das
heißt man hat nicht alle Kräfte an einer
zentralenstelle einsetzen können sondern
man hat sie an drei Stellen aufgeteilt
und das hat unter anderem dazu geführt
dass es zu diesem Ergebnis gekommen
ist die ukinische Seite war gezwungen
tatsächlich einen gefechtstechnik und
taktikwechsel durchzuführen nachdem man
erkannt hat dass der Ansatz so wie er
tatsächlich vorgetragen worden ist nicht
funktioniert hat hat man versucht eine
Veränderung durchzuführen dazu muss man
ganz kurz uns das uns das Gelände
ansehen das Gelände in den benannten
Räumen ist sehr sehr flach tatsächlich
ist es so dass die sogenannten taktisch
zusammengehörigen Geländeteile sich
dadurch darstellen dass große Weizen
oder Getreidefelder durch einzelne
Baumreihen getrennt sind das heiß die
Ukraine hat zuerst versucht mit den
mechanisierten Verbänden von einem Feld
wenn man das vergleicht mit einem
Schachbrett ins nächste zu ziehen und
ist dann quasi in diesen Feldern aus
einem Mix von Kampfhubschraubern Panzer
bei lenkwaffentrups Minenfeldern und
anderen Systemen wie kamelkaz drohen
abgewehrt worden general salusen hat
angeordnet hier einen gefechtstechnik
und taktikwechsel durchzuführen das
heißt man hat quasi davon abgesehen mit
größeren Kampfgruppen anzugreifen
sondern man hat kleine Angriffsgruppen
gebildet die vor allem versucht haben in
diesen windschutzgürtel vorzustoßen das
heißt man hat versucht wieder der
Vergleich mit dem Schachbrett zwischen
den Feldern vor zustoßen und quasi von
einem Feld in das andere entsprechend zu
wirken das hat auch tatsächlich
funktioniert aber es war sehr sehr
verlustreich und man ist nur sehr sehr
langsam vorangekommen oft nur wenige 100
mer in der
Woche nach den Betrachtungen auf
taktischer und operativer Ebene sehen
wir uns ganz kurz die Ergebnisse auf der
strategischen Ebene an was wurde
tatsächlich erreicht und diese Karte
stellt das sehr gut da denn wir erkennen
hier das Ergebnis der ukrainischen
Vorstöße in diesen 195 Tagen und auf der
anderen Seite auch das Ergebnis der
russischen Angri ffe hier in blau
eingezeichnet die drei
Angriffsrichtungen der Ukraine einmal
hier dieser 8 bis 10 km Tiefe Vorstoß
nördlich der Stadt dokm bzw militopol
ostws davon der Vorstoß ebenfalls 10 bis
12 km nördlich von bertansk und mariopol
und der Versuch hier bei bakmut nördlich
bzw südlich weiter anzugreifen in dieser
Zeit hat Russland ebenfalls versucht der
Geländegewinne durchzuführen und man
erkennt an den roten Ergebnissen wo ist
der russischen Seite gelungen ist
entsprechend vorzustoßen das heißt
abschließend muss man klar sagen dass
das strategische Ziel das man erreichen
wollte nämlich der Effekt dass man die
Russen an den verhandlungsch zwingt
durch das Trennen der russisch besetzten
Gebiete so nicht erreicht worden ist im
Gegenteil es ist sogar so dass vor allem
die Brigaden der Offensive vor allem die
westlich ausgestatteten plus die drei
ukrainischen tatsächlich abgenützt
worden sind bzw zum Teil jetzt bereits
an anderen Stellen der Front sind im
Einsatz sind man sieht es z.B an der 47
mechbrigade die vor kurzem verlegt
worden ist aus dem Zentralraum in den
Raum auf dieevka um dort quasi den
russischen Angriffen etwas
entgegenzusetzen das Beispiel dass ich
dazu heranziehe ist das Beispiel des
Allierten Durchbruches in der Normandie
1944 im Juli 1944 wo es die
amerikanischen Streitkräfte geschafft
haben im Prinzip einen Durchbruch zu
erzielen aus den Lande und Brückenköpfen
auszubrechen und dann schlussendlich die
deutschen Kräfte einzukesseln und
tatsächlich zu vernichten der
entscheidende Unterschied von heute zu
damals war dass am Beginn dieser
Offensive die amerikanische Seite
versucht hat mit massiven Einsatz von
Luftunterstützung mit flächenbombardma
in einem definierten Raum die deutschen
Verteidigungsstellungen so zu schwächen
dass man tatsächlich dann mit drei
Panzerdivisionen durchbrechen konnte und
genau diese Vorbereitung dieses quasi
vorbereiten auch der gegnerischen
Stellungen das hat so am Beginn der
ukrainischen Offensive nicht tatsächlich
stattgefunden und hat somit auch
wesentlich dazu beigetragen dass die
Offensive nicht erfolgreich war im
Vergleich zu diesem Beispiel außer dem
Sommer
1944 während auf der ukrainischen Seite
die Ergebnisse der Offensive mit großer
nüchterung aufgenommen worden sind war
es so dass auf der russischen Seite der
abwehrfolk natürlich entscheidend auf
die Moral auch der russischen Soldaten
eine Einwirkung hatte auch hier ist
wichtig zu verstehen dass Russland in
seiner Propaganda versucht an die
narrative des sogenannten Großen
Vaterländischen Krieges im Zweiten
Weltkrieg anzuknüpfen wir sehen das auch
an unterschiedlichen Darstellungen so
z.B wie hier wo das sowjetische Soldat
erfolgreich war gegen deutschen
tigerpanzer hier wiedergespiegelt der
russische Soldat von heute der
erfolgreich gegen die Deutschen
leopardpanzer sich tatsächlich behauptet
hat oder auch gegen die amerikanisch
gelieferten Bradley kampfschützenpanzer
das heißt was also hier entscheidend ist
zu verstehen ist dass man das narrativ
dass man bis jetzt hatte dass der
russische Soldat nicht in der Lage ist
quasi einen Kampf zu führen und sein
Kampfwert gering ist zu überdenken ist
im Gegenteil es war so dass die
russischen Soldaten tatsächlich es
geschafft haben nach der entsprechenden
Vorbereitungsphase die ukrainische
Offensive
abzuwehren und hier sind wir beim
größten Fehler der passieren kann und
das ist der den Gegner zu unterschätzen
ich gebe Ihnen hier auch das eine oder
andere Beispiel beginnen wir mit den
Einsatz der russischen Luftabwehr bzw
auch der Einsatz der russischen Luft
Streitkräfte hier ist es so dass auch
der britische Nachrichtendienst
eingestehen muss dass die ukrainischen
Kräfte große Probleme haben
durchzustoßen hinsichtlich quasi des
Einsatzes ihrer Luftwaffe gegenüber den
russischen fliegerystemen und dass diese
sehr erfolgreich sind und zwar nicht nur
was den Einsatz gegen die ukrainische
Luftwaffe betrifft sondern auch vor
allem den Einsatz gegen Drohnen aber
auch gegen entsprechende Luftboden oder
bodenbodenwaffensysteme also das
Beispiel z.B das stormshadow oder auch
das vom Heimat eingesetzten raketenypst
der gmls dasatsäichlich gelingt es den
Russen diese Kräfte zu bekämpfen und
diese Raketen auch abzuschießen auf der
anderen Seite sehen wir dass Russland in
der Lage ist sich anzupassen indem es
mit sehr einfachen Möglichkeiten große
Erfolge erzielt ein Beispiel dafür ist
der Einsatz von eigentlich sogenannten
dummen freifallbomben die mit einem
Anbausatz so intelligent gemacht werden
dass ihr sichere Entfernung also
außerhalb der Reichweite der ischen
fliegabwehr in Richtung des Gegners und
in diesem fallukrenischen Streitkräfte
abgefeuert werden können das heißt man
nimmt das eine 500 oder 1000 Kil Bombe
baut diesen Anbausatz an und kann dann
GPS gesteuert diese Bombe quasi ins Ziel
bringen und hier kann man erkennen dass
S mittlerweile in der Lage ist diese
Systeme zu Dutzenden pro Tag einzusetzen
zusätzlich zu anderen Systemen wie
marschflohkörper ballistischen Raketen
die ebenfalls in großer stückzah
vorhanden sind und hier ist es so dass
man sich sogar eingestehen musste auf
westlicher Seite dass die Produktion an
diesem prozessionswaffensystemen das
Vorkriegsniveau bereits überstiegen hat
das heißt nicht nur 100 pro Monat
sondern weit über 100 pro Monat an
dieser Stelle auch ein kurzes Video dass
den Einsatz von diesen sogenannten
Freifall Bomben zeigt auf ukrainische
Ziele vor allen
[Musik]
Bereitstellungsräume
nach dem offensichtlichen Misserfolg der
ukrainischen Offensive war es klar dass
die Unterstützer der Ukraine Handeln
mussten was hat man getan man hat
versucht quasi einen Ausgleich zu
erzielen durch die Lieferung von
speziellen Waffensystemen es kam
tatsächlich zur Lieferung von der von
den ukrainen herbeigesehen
Munitionssorte der sogenannten Camps der
Army tactical missile hier wurde eine
gewisse Stückzahl man nimmt an zwischen
20 und 30 geliefert um tatsächlich die
Ukraine in die Lage zu versetzen mit
diesem System den Russen wieder
kritische Schläge zuzuführen aber wie
gesagt die eine sehr begrenzte Stückzahl
der folg dieser attchams war sofort der
Käber denn was hat die Ukraine gemacht
man hat versucht die gefährlichste Waffe
der Russen auszuschalten und das ist vor
allem der Einsatz der russischen
Kampfhubschrauber der sich vorher in
Beginn der Offensive dargestellt hat man
hat also versucht diese zu treffen indem
man mit diesen gelieferten Boden
bodenraketensystemen begonnen hat und
dem Einsatz von sogenannter
kastermunition diese absprungplätze der
russischen luftwafee anzugreifen und
hier erkennen wir auf diesem Bild
tatsächlich auch den folg den Erfolg
dieses Einsatzes wo es gelang eine nicht
geringe Anzahl von diesen russischen
kampfupschauern zu zerstören aber der
Einsatz war einmalig und begrenzt und
hat also nicht diesen durchschlagenden
Erfolg erzielt den man eigentlich
brauchen würde um der Offensive den den
weiteren Durchbruch zu
ermöglichen das er führt im Ergebnis
dazu dass General sol der
Oberkommandierende der ischen
Streitkräfte eine sehr mutige Maßnahme
getroffen hat er hat nämlich in der
Öffentlichkeit verkündet dass die
Situation an der Front prekär ist dass
es im Prinzip einen Art Pat Zustand gibt
zwischen beiden Seiten und dass es es
wesentliche Elemente braucht um diesen
Pat zu Zustand zu durbrechen und in
einem aufsehenen Artikel im konomist
versucht hat das auch kurz darzustellen
und zu erklären und er sagt er braucht
eine Art Wunderwaffe aus diesem
pzzustand herauszukommen was meint er im
Kern er meint vor allem dass der Einsatz
von vielen vielen drohen vielen vielen
tausenden Drohnen auf beiden Seiten dazu
führt dass keine der beiden Seiten
einerseits Kräfte bereitstellen kann
aber vor allem in die Offensive gehen
kann denn wenn immer Kräfte
bereitgestellt werden also größere
Anzahl von Panzern kampfschützenpanzern
erkennt der andere das und setzt Drohnen
nicht nur zur Aufklärung ein sondern vor
allem zur Zerstörung dieser Kräfte das
heißt es kommt das aus der
Bereitstellung nie zu einem Manöver
durch die Aufkärung des der
drohnensysteme und vor allem durch den
Einsatz von Drohnen als
Angriffswaffe und hier sticht ein
besonderer drohnentyp besonders heraus
und das ist die sogenannte first person
view Drohne ein Mittel das man sehr
leicht und mit wenigen Mitteln erzeugen
kann das aber auch tatsächlich in der
Lage ist sogar eine Kampfbahn so zu
zerstören hier setzen beide Seiten diese
Drohnen ein auch in einer improvisierten
Art und Weise also die ukrainische Seite
die isto hier einfache Drohnen verwendet
und hier bestehende Gefechtsköpfe an
diese anbringt um diese dann einzusetzen
oder auch die russische Seite die aber
den großen Vorteil hat dass sie diese
sogar industriell produzieren kann im
nächsten Video möchten wir Ihnen zeigen
den erfolgreichen Einsatz von einer
derartigen russischen first person vi
Drohne gegen einen ukrainischen Leopard
Kampfpanzer
das Dilemma besteht darin dass die
russische Seite nach wie vor einem
funktionierenden militärisch
industriellen Komplex hat der auf
Hochturm produziert während die
ukrainische Seite die unter den Angriff
auf die strategische Infrastruktur des
Landes leidet gezwungen ist in kleinen
und mehr oder weniger überschaubaren
Werkstätten diese Drohnen zu erzeugen
ein Beispiel für die
Leistungsbereitschaft der russischen des
russisch militärischen industriellen
komplex ist der Erzeugung von speziellen
drohnentrüppen wie z.B der Drohne vom
Typ landset diese militärische
industrielle gefertigte Drohne macht es
den Russen möglich auch tief hinter der
Front wirksam zu werden also 70 80 km
hinter den frontlinen was sich für die
ukrainische Seite verherend auswirkt
denn wenn es den Russen gelingt durch
Aufkärung z.B Kampfflugzeuge der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe vor denen es
nicht mehr viele gibt tatsächlich zu
erkennen dann ist es möglich mit diesen
drohnensystemen diese auch anzugreifen
das heißt die Russen haben eine
Kombination von aufklärungsdrohnen
Stichwort Hunter und kamikaz Drohnen
Stichwort Killer um diese Systeme zu
zerstören und wir zeigen ihen hier als
Beispiel zwei Videos die die Zerstörung
einer ukrainischen su25 und einer
ukrainischen MiG 29
zeigen
als Ergebnis dieser Betrachtungen muss
man feststellen dass der Krieg damit
weitergehen wird das heißt nach 195
Tagen Offensive kann man sagen dass
diese ukinische Offensive nicht den
gewünschten Erfolg erzielt hat und nach
660 Tagen Krieg ist es schlussendlich
auch der ukrainische Generalstabschef
der sagt die Situation gleich der eines
Pat Zustandes das bedeutet dass in den
unterschiedlichen Frontlinien in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten weitere
Kämpfe zu erwarten sind sehen wir uns
ganz kurz die einzelnen Abschnitte der
Front an und versuchen kurz zu bewerten
wie sich das Gefecht weiterentwickeln
kann beginnen wir mit dem sogenannten
nördlichen Sektor der ca 1200 K km
langen Frontlinie hier sticht ins Auge
dass Russland wie letztes Jahr im Winter
offensichtlich versucht an vielen
Stellen der Front anzugreifen um die
Ukraine zu zwingen ihre regional also
taktischen Reserven bzw auch
überregional als operativen Reserven
einzusetzen bzw letzter Konsequenz auch
sie zwingt keine strategischen reserv
mehr zu bilden weil sie quasi diese an
der Front verbraucht hier kennt man das
z.B im Raum zwischen kupiansk und
swarowe also ostwärts des Fluss
ostkülles zu sehr intensiven Angriffen
der russischen Seite kommt diese
Angriffe setzen sich südlich davon im
Raum parark Mut fort woer im Prinzip der
dritte stoßkeil der Ukraine am 4 Juni
begonnen hat und hier ist es so dass die
Russen es geschafft haben dass ter dass
die Ukrainer in den letzten 1990 Tag in
Besitz genommen haben zum Teil wieder
zurückzuobern und zwar im Raum kromowo
und glisevka nördlich und südlich von
bakmut wenn wir weiter Richtung Süden
gehen so sind wir im Bereich grob um die
Stadt stetzk hier kennt man auf der
anderen Seite dass auch der massive
Einsatz von russischen Kräften nicht für
die russische Seite zu erfolgen sondern
zu massiven Verlusten führt wie wir das
gesehen haben im auf dieevka wo die
russische Seite versucht hat in einer
Zangenbewegung bis jetzt mehrmals die
Stadt einzunehmen aber hier sehr schwere
Verluste erlitten hat daran im Anschluss
gelang es jed Dooch Marinka tatsächlich
in Besitz zu nehmen und auch weiter
intensive Angriffe werden geführt bei
ugla und bei
ä das ist der Bereich wo der zweite Stoß
der Ukraine im Juni damals stattgefunden
hat wo auch hier die Russen ist
geschafft haben diesen Stoß im Prinzip
Einhalt zugebieten bzw auch wieder
langsam
vorzurücken wenn wir uns noch den
Bereich des Südens ansehen so kann man
erkennen dass auch beim Stoß quasi der
bei rapotine Richtung Süden vorgetragen
wird der Ukraine ist nicht gelungen ist
signifikant mehr Raum zu gewinnen im
Gegenteil es kam also auch hier zu
intensiven Gefechten und zu einer
massiven aufnutzung der ukrainischen
Kräfte und auch hier ist es so dass
Russland und Unterstützung seiner
Fähigkeiten die
Kampfhubschrauber aber auch der Einsatz
der taktischen luftwarfee in der Lage
ist nicht nur diese Linie zu halten
sondern zum Teil auch wieder Gelände
Besitz zu nehmen ein Erfolg für die
Ukraine stellt sich vor allem ostwärts
der Stadt kerson da wo man es geschafft
hat einen kleinen Brückenkopf auf der
anderen Seite des knpos zu bilden nicht
nur hier sondern auch an anderen Stellen
hier ist vor allem die Idee des Gefechts
durch diese Griffe zu zeigen dass die
Ukraine in der Lage ist das Momentum
weiter aufrechtzuhalten und auch Druck
auf die Russen auszuüben denn die Russen
sind natürlich gezwungen Kräfte die sie
möglicherweise an ander Stelle brauchen
hierher zu verlegen um diesen
Brückenkopf zu bekämpfen eine
tatsächliche Erfolgsgeschichte für die
Ukraine ist aber der Einsatz ihrer
Mittel in der schwarz im Schwarzen Meer
hier ist es tatsächlich gelungen der
Ukraine die russische Schwarzmeerflotte
aus dem Westen des Schwarzen Meeres
zurückzudringen das begann vorer mit dem
Einnahme der sogenannten Schlangeninsel
und setzte sich fort vor allem durch den
Einsatz von unbemannten Systemen aber
auch noch einmal der
su24m mit den luftbodensystemen skalpon
Storm Shadow wo es es gelungen ist
tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe von
russischen Schiffen zu zerstören oder
zumindest schwer zu beschädigen neben
diesen taktisch operativen hin und her
darf man nicht vergessen dass vor allem
die strategische Ebene entscheidend ist
und hier ist es so dass man davon
ausgehen kann dass Russland versucht nun
in diesem zweiten Winter neuerlich eine
strategische luftkampagne gegen die
kritische Infrastruktur der Raine
durchzuführen bereits letzten Winter ist
es gelungen ca zwischen 50 und 60% laut
ukrainischen offiziellen der kritischen
Infrastruktur zu zerstören die Ukraine
konnte ca 10 bis 15% wieder instand
setzen aber die Frage ist gelingt es die
restlichen 50% knapp durch den Winter zu
bringen vor all anbedach dessen dass
Russland beginnt nicht nur wieder mit
seinem marschfkörpern sondern vor allem
auch mit dem massiven Einsatz von aus
dem Iran gelieferten Drohnen die
mittlerweile auch selbst in Russland
erzeugt werden Einsätze zu fliegen es
ist hier vor allem das Modell Shahid 131
136 bzw kündigt sich offensichtlich an
dass auch ein neues Modell bereits
verwendet wird das wesentlich schneller
als das alte ist und damit auch schwerer
zu bekämpfen ist damit erkennt man
natürlich dass der Druck sehr groß ist
auf die ukrainische fliegerer trotz auch
der Lieferung von westlichen Systemen
allein an dieser Karte erkennt man den
Einsatz der russischen marsflugkörper
und drohen zwischen September und
November und man kann erkennen dass es
quasi hier versucht wird vor allem in
die Tiefe des Landes zu wirken warum
weil es einerseits hier von russischer
Seite vermutet wird dass vor allem diese
so24m stationiert sind bzw anderserseits
sich auch hier zentrale
versorgungsdepots befinden die man
zerstören möchte und damit quasi der
ukrainischen Seite die Grundlage für ein
Kampf nehmen möchte und das ist das
entscheidende denn auf der strategischen
Ebene ist es auch wichtig zu verstehen
dass die Ukraine natürlich in ihrem cent
of gravity abhängig ist von den
Lieferungen des Westens und hier kann
man erkennen dass es in den letzten
Monaten zu einem signifikanten Einbruch
gek kommen ist der Lieferungen und der
Hilfszusagen aus dem Westen Richtung
Ukraine und hier macht vor allem die USA
den Unterschied wo wir jetzt erkennen
dass es zu einem großen Streit
mittlerweile kommt ob jetzt weitere
Hilfsgelder zu Verfügung gestellt werden
oder nicht ist aber wichtig zu verstehen
dass die Ukraine weiteres Material
braucht möchte sie quasi wieder im
nächsten Frühjahr z.B tatsächlich in die
Offensive gehen oder auch möchte sie
quasi in einer defensiven Einsatzführung
den Russen etwas entgegenzuhalten das
heißt sie braucht weitere vor allem
Kampffahrzeuge Kampfpanzer
kampfschützenpanzertilleriesysteme um
den Kampf weiterzuführen und und das ist
das Wichtige und entscheidend sie
braucht vor allem weitere Soldaten um
tatsächlich diese Fahrzeuge nicht nur zu
bemannen sondern auch die Kräfte zur
Verfügung zu haben und die Frage ist
natürlich hat die Ukraine demografisch
die Möglichkeiten und was hier diesen
langen Krieg
weiterzuführen damit ist klar der Krieg
ist nicht zu Ende sondern er geht weiter
und der Präsident selenski hat vor
kurzem sehahr drastisch zum Ausdruck
gebracht dass es zumindest ein Erfolg
ist dass sie nicht quasi sich
zurückziehen sondern quasi das gewonnene
Gelände halten dass sie zwar sich
vorgenommen hätten bessere und
beitreichende Ergebnisse zu erzielen die
nicht gelungen sind aber dass man weiter
verbissen kämpft und dass man daran
glaubt dass man die Ukraine quasi wieder
in ihren Grenzen herstellen können damit
bin ich am Ende unserer heutigen
Präsentation ich bedanke mich fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten
Mal